such a darkness yeah
yeah those dark edge dolls
oh
oh you tricked me there bob you got me
to kill my family
[Laughter]
high breath
oh we just yeah jlegg just said r.i.p
nor mcdonald yeah did you know norm
yeah
we shot our hbo specials on the same
night uh in chicago yeah
61.
yeah
he he battled well
he was strong man
you know
yeah god damn it
he fought he was a
he's about one of the funniest guys i've
ever seen and he was also great at
improv incredibly sharp and improv
great impressionist all these things he
never got credit for he's a good actor
he was a great actor he was he did lots
of things really well he's great writer
yeah i thought his book was one of the
best
just just the funniest thing i've read
in such a long time
put it was like an improv mind put into
a book form and i was just blown away by
i thought it was just absolutely
hilarious i listened to it in audio and
then read it
and i laughed both times i was like this
is just incredible writing throughout it
all
yeah he can make you that's see it's a
separate gift you guys out there
watching
to
you know you ever see the comedy act and
everyone says in the audience going
yeah he's good he's a good writer
santa joke you know you know the santa
jokes for me the east coast west coast
santa
east coast
west coast santa ah that's funny
[Laughter]
oh that's great
that's funny
someone that like knew their voice like
there's there's like rarely like a more
unique voice than norms he really tapped
into that
oh man he had a sound it was
unmistakable
and
[Laughter]
such a darkness yeah
those dark edge dolls
oh oh you tricked me there bob you got
me to kill my family
[Laughter]
oh you fooled me oh i was just kidding
and it's such a contrast to how he comes
off physically so there's like already a
misdirect built into like his content
versus how it's coming off you know i
know
i know
sorry to bring that down there rick but
yeah
it just all happened yeah yeah so
oh my god it's a shocking shocking loss
he was a great
great uh a great friend too he's a
really good guy just a nice guy
high breath